los países en desarrollo alertan de las
consecuencias de no vacunar rápido tanto
para el comercio mundial como por la
posibilidad de que surjan nuevas
variantes que puedan inhabilitar las
vacunas ante este panorama crecen las
voces para que se suspendan las patentes
y seguimos pidiendo a las empresas que
compartan sus conocimientos propiedad
intelectual y datos con otros
fabricantes de vacunas calificados e
incluso países de ingresos medios aunque
por lo tanto para impulsar el
crecimiento el comercio y los medios de
vida
necesitamos vacunas para todo aquel que
lo necesite desde octubre del año pasado
la organización mundial del comercio
tiene una propuesta de sudáfrica e india
países fabricantes de vacunas para que
los productos contra el cob y 19no estén
sujetos a patentes
la propuesta es apoyada por una gran
lista de países mientras que se niegan
los más ricos como los que integran la
unión europea y eeuu
s
y yo en junio en eeuu y la unión europea
dicen que no están preparados para abrir
la patente de la vacuna que no están
preparados para compartir el
conocimiento para que otros países
empiecen a producirla entonces no sólo
compramos todas las dosis sino que
impedimos que otros produzcan
con giuseppe las farmacéuticas alegan
que la competencia favorece que se
produzca más mientras que activistas
aseguran que de las 12 millones de
vacunas actuales fabricadas diariamente
liberando la patente se podría pasar a
60 millones sin embargo en esta lucha
por las patentes cada vez más
parlamentarios europeos y congresistas
estadounidenses apoyan que haya una
liberación temporal mientras que méxico
a partir de una patente de la escuela
estadounidense mount sinai está cerca de
empezar ensayos clínicos de su vacuna
patria